all right red
hello red oh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
[ __ ] i'm from everywhere sam gabriel
pasadena ontario
it was most of my childhood
las vegas compton
tell me about your family yeah you had
mom and dad um yeah my mom was german
my stepdad he was white and i have my
real dad creole and jeff and and um
east carol
and uh so i was makes a mix of black and
white basically and you identify as what
black you do absolutely
it's just it's just natural it comes
naturally to me interesting
am i blood i'm it is what it is
and uh how would you describe your
childhood
um it was um i was
not sure
yeah not sure what i did a lot of things
growing up i just didn't understand um
i uh
was a nervous child
um and i and i was an embarrassed child
embarrassed yeah
it's crazy because i think of different
moments
um i don't know of myself i think or
like looking um
looking at a place when i was a child
seriously like putting
long socks with sandals on used to
pissing me off when i was like five
years old so i used to be embarrassed
because she would make me go to school
and my hair was short i'd either have a
pro or a short haircut
she didn't know what to do with me
but i looked back and i was like it's
cute but i was like lost like what the
[ __ ]
and uh you finished high school
i finished um
colleen i got my associate's degree
i didn't
actually finish high school i just
skipped that and went to college because
i had my son
at an early age and i just you know
well i was 15 when i had him
so uh i started going to college and
working at that time yeah and so back to
your childhood i mean no crazy abuse
around like that i um
so i was i was
12
you know um
and i got raped by two guys
one was older one was younger they kind
of held me captive or hostage you know
i'm saying pretty much i was a virgin
you know and so it kind of is it 12
years old yeah i was 12. so i didn't i
didn't know how to fight back you know
what i'm saying
and so somehow
man uh
they take me back to this apartment
and um
some guys came in like a couple hours
later
this is like a movie and they came in
because they seen us earlier we're
younger they were older
um
and my friend went out and told him what
was going on because i was there for
like 12 hours when who was younger you
and
who you said we were younger me well i
was younger me and my friend that was
there oh you're a friend yeah but they
were you know
13 and 14 already having sex and [ __ ] so
here i am
this naive child
so that was that and um some guys came
out of nowhere and [ __ ]
got me out of there somehow and i ended
up going home and
that's all she was some guys came in and
said yeah yeah how long have you helped
me
how long were you held
i was there i was like it would seem
like like 12 hours i was gone
i was supposed to be home at eight at
night and
i didn't go home until like eight in the
morning
i walked home yeah
this was a that was in ontario
and
so ontario was
whack and then we moved to vegas
and you know
they didn't like me there
so i was always fighting i'm always
fighting i'm a fighter you're a fighter
i'm a defensive i'm very defensive
so yeah i'm a fighter
i can be a lover but
you know
i'm just defensive you have kids
yeah he's 26 now 26. yeah he lives in
new york
he majored he got his degree in
bastion institute of merchandise okay
yeah he went to bed him smart
smartest cat i know you raised him
all by myself
basically until you know i got married
but from 15 until you know like 20. you
know that was my kid
i was responsible
i had to be but i was going through some
weird [ __ ] i was always in abusive
relationships you know i'm saying that
no matter what i still came out standing
and my son would still be right there
with me no matter how many bags we had
to carry due to from the greyhound to
[ __ ] you know with our and the little
boy was
strong so 15 to 20 you raise him by
yourself yeah and just going through
hell and then you got married and then i
got married
and uh
that's all she wrote for like 14 years
i was in a relationship
he was wonderful he's a great man
he
has and had my back he's just you know
we were young
and
times changed people's mental change and
it just didn't work
you know
plus i had to
it was good timing that we separated
because i had to go take care of my mom
before she passed
and i was there every day with her and
then the day i decided to go out she
passes away fire department calls yeah
yeah same thing happened to my brother
i'm sorry yeah my brother was my
everything he just got killed in like
2017.
but that was my you know my ace
how'd he get killed uh you know gang
banging and
dope dealing oh wow yeah he was good at
it
so you ended up in the streets too
yeah we was out there me and my brother
we feel like i guess we probably i don't
know we had to
you know uh every man for himself in our
family you know what i'm saying
and rest in peace to my parents i'm not
saying
they bad people or anything but you
didn't really learn a lot from them we
learned a lot from the streets and
that's how me and my brother
you know ended up having the same type
of like mental
and uh
but yeah he was a gang banging
and a good good dope man
i love him
so and he was a youngster so you're
working where do you work now
i work i'm i'm i hustle
yeah i also um there's no shame in my
game i uh
that's how i get it you know it's good
because i meet
different people every day i meet some
good ass people
you know
people god brings people into your life
for a reason and it's not that i'm just
sucking a dick or giving up my [ __ ] i
have to sit there and we have three and
four hour conversations
yeah it's just
you know you learn something new every
day
and these people
are good people
you know that it seems to me as if
anybody i do meet or you know have a
date with because that's what i'm doing
and i do it well um
they always come back it's a
one relationship you know what i'm
saying and it's friendship and yeah i
meet a lot of good people you make
connections absolutely because you can
speak so
yeah you're good you're good
no you're a communicator so yeah
excuse me i'm my
stupid ass mouth
you know this happened from a [ __ ]
knocking my teeth out when this happened
[ __ ] like three three months ago and he
was my friend
and i'm gonna talk about it because you
know who
you know if he feels a certain kind of
way that's on you
you know what i'm saying
i still look like this
you can feel whatever you want but i
look like this streets are right right
right
you've had other things happen to you
um i'm like i said i i'm always i'm um
like i said i'm defensive so i'm always
on the defense mode and i think i can
just
whoop the world yeah i feel like i can't
be touched for some reason you know what
i'm saying in my mind so i like i said
i'm always
people misunderstand me or whatever it
is but i i'm always getting into it with
somebody you know i've probably had like
five or six bites
within the last year which is pathetic
i'm 41 years old
how did you first get into this line of
work uh
i learned early that
you know before i had my son when i was
like 13 or 14
that you know
men when they come see you they have to
bring you something bring you some
that's you know what my how my dad did
when he came to visit he would come see
me and he would come with stuff so i'm
like oh this is how it works
yeah and then so when i when somebody
would see me because i was always a cute
child you know what i'm saying but as
growing up um
not i'm not being conceited or nothing
but this is you know i've always been um
attractive to
people you know
and um
so you learned early on that
men
will bring you gifts
yeah so [ __ ] a gift i want some money no
i want some money money's a gift and i
learned that [ __ ] from
yeah what is it
is it real or [ __ ]
it's either yeah
you've been doing this for how long
since since you're a teenager yeah off
and on though but i've been in
relationships you know what i'm saying
so
so you take a break for a while
i guess if you call it a break it's not
like
that's well i probably is my first job
of choice
i was saying
it's not like that but it probably is
though so i could be doing something i
would you know did you have dreams of
doing something else with your life when
you were young i don't know
you just wanted me to start i have no
idea i didn't know what i wanted to be
i'm a pisces so i'm i was could be i
didn't know which way to go
oh [ __ ]
yeah what is it what is this lifestyle
dude
it makes look when i was i haven't
really been in no [ __ ] except like
when i told you when i was 12 but when i
being in this because i was an escort in
vegas at one point you know what i'm
saying and then i just do my my
independent work look at
trying to flip my wig um but
it um
i learned i learned
like i said i meet good people but it's
not
i'm not bragging about it because who
wants to [ __ ] they call [ __ ]
day long
you know
[ __ ] it's nothing to brag about but i do
it well do you find this work and people
are happy do you find that
yes
you get a lot of
return customers no absolutely but i'm
just being honest i um
it's nothing to brag about of course i
want to be that lady in the red suit
with the um
skirt and the [ __ ] red jacket and her
[ __ ] afghan dog with the long hair
and her [ __ ] mercedes getting out the
car trying to sell this million dollar
house to these people
that's that's reality
[Music]
does this
do you find this work degrading or do
you find it it builds up here it's so
degrading is it degrading absolutely
yeah this is if somebody says look i
have to play a part
and i play my part well you know what
i'm saying so it's it's
degrading um in my own mind because
i know i'm what i can do but [ __ ] this
is what i do and i do it well so i'm not
really um
hurt by it or you know like the norm
you know they probably think i'm crazy
but
it's it's just something that i it's
just what happened it's just what it's
for me right now it's what's for me all
the time because if it wasn't this i'll
be a nurse talking to people you know
what i'm saying or whatever else kind of
job i had i'm talking
i'm getting to you know
uh
yeah
where do you stay now you're in you're
you have your own place or you're i'm
staying
of course hotels i've been staying in
hotels for like three [ __ ] years and
you just don't realize how long
dog you've been out there that shit's
crazy tell me about staying a motel
hotel it's so [ __ ] bad like right now
like my friend just came over and said
well
you're in a motel but i'm like hold on
this is not a motel
i was like this is an extended stay what
do you mean like
like that's my house [ __ ] and i've been
doing this [ __ ] for months and it's
it's
that shit's expensive and it's pathetic
that i just don't take time out to go
and find me a [ __ ] real house you
know what i'm saying i've been there
done that but being in the streets and
what i do
it's it's
my i don't want to miss nothing my
viewers even i am mystified as wives
none of these girls will get an
apartment
why none of the girls that are working
like figaro street will get an apartment
yeah they all seem to just go night by
night you just live day to day i mean i
understand it could be a place for you
to do business sometimes but
all the time pretty much that's how we
don't even do that they just have it
separately from where they sleep yeah no
i don't i [ __ ]
i make sure that i my [ __ ] is is
presented well too so
i'm gonna get but getting an apartment
just doesn't happen why because you're
you're credited
my credit and just me taking the time
out you know i'm
to take time out to handle business
you know what i'm saying i mean there's
something that's what this should do
because you don't want to you don't want
to go and stand in a line at no [ __ ]
dmv i don't want to pay people to do
that [ __ ] for me all right guys you know
there's something money to go make like
that's just pathetic there's something
about this lifestyle that's just very
you just wing it you're constantly
winging it absolutely but i don't know
well yeah but
in terms of like
having credit and having yeah that [ __ ]
is barely
you have to know somebody
[Laughter]
we have to know somebody everyone's just
flying by the seat of their pants
you just want to hope you know somebody
and your your hours are typically what
you work through the night 24 or 7.
it's some days that i it's crazy that i
went through three days it's crazy how
like on figaro street the busiest time
will be from like midnight to like seven
a.m absolutely that's because you know
most especially like between four and
seven a.m is the busiest time of the day
right so that's some people can't make
their own decisions on what time they
want to go outside but i can't so i'd be
outside 24 7.
i'm on my phone really
if you if you're driving figaro street
at nine o'clock at night i've seen it
there's nobody there i've seen it but
then at six in the morning so it'll be
perfect for me to go on video at nine
o'clock
i'll be the only one out there you ever
worked with a pimp never kind of not
really
that's good no
um
he wasn't pimping me he
was my friend
yeah yeah they're always they're always
boyfriends and then they're but when i
met him we he never went against me
spend my money on me he did me good i
know it might sound crazy but i've had
people that it's been you know brothers
out there that you know want to fight me
or hit me upside my head and [ __ ] cuz i
won't give them no money and [ __ ] like
it's i go through that i go through that
you know often apparently you know what
i'm saying
um
but it's just it's hard you want to
[ __ ]
choose up
[Laughter]
and are so drugs are part of your life
um most definitely that's the only way i
would be doing this
so the drug addiction drives you or
it makes me want to go get some more
money yeah right
it's all your level it's not just for
the drug addiction because i get that
[ __ ] for free you know what i'm saying
but it's the drug that makes you want to
just go whether it's you know going to
go
um
water somebody's grass or whatever
you're going to do you just
you just go you know
that's our thing that's what we do we
get dressed up smoke to go outside
you're talking about
crazy 41 years old
yeah crack is here right most definitely
yeah
and that's um
it's a cold addiction
it's a cold one but you know you can
call it what you want oh that's just an
excuse
addiction whatever habit hobby yeah
lifestyle
enjoy it perhaps
and not ready to quit sometimes do you
think a woman was meant you know
doing this kind of work is okay for a
woman
no but what would you say to a young
girl who's thinking about doing go to
school
i mean what else can i say go to school
get a [ __ ] education
you know think of a business that you
want to come up with it just seems like
it'd be hard to like
love is an important part of a human's
life right
and and this is the worst emotion they
have
what's that love is the worst emotion
they have but it's also the best
they can get the best it can be painful
and it can be the most wonderful thing
you ever experienced
but i don't think you'll ever experience
it by doing this kind of work
that's crazy very rare that you think
that
a lot of people um
use the word love
yeah i mean it's has very different
definitions for different people
yeah but what was what was the best
example of a loving relationship you had
in your life that you ever saw as a kid
that i ever saw as a kid yeah like your
parents are in my parents didn't talk
about [ __ ]
they act like everything was
you know
they spent eight hundred dollars on
vacuum cleaners and [ __ ] when we needed
a school shop
was there anyone you saw that like they
did not i didn't see them do anything
but i've seen like cheap like this this
deceit
that's what i've seen you know from
yeah my mother rest in peace yeah most
definitely but um
yeah i you know i've seen abuse
with my like not my within my family
household but another family
um
yeah
see a lot of [ __ ] yeah so are you lonely
most of the time
absolutely even though you're
absolutely meeting lots of people you're
so lonely even though
even though i'm
i i have friends
that i feel responsible for
you know
um i don't know why and even if i don't
even know if they're my friends because
i thought my friend was my friend when
he did this but
i um
so i'm not even all the way right but i
look out we all you know
and you know so i keep those type of
people around me
because we're gonna you know and it's
not like
a good influence it's crazy
like you know that shit's crazy
but it's what i choose these people are
good people
you know i i we those are my people
i'm i'm i have them around me
so i'm not lonely
what is the most misunderstood thing
in your opinion of this of girls that do
this kind of work
they have no uh the misunderstand
is that
they don't
we don't
want to do this forever
that's what's misunderstood
but it might be in us forever
yeah it's interesting a lot of the
women i'll talk to will say
hey i'll ask them do you like the guys
that pick you up the tricks
and they'll say no
no it's just it's just doing it purely
for the money
but they won't get out no matter what
times have changed are you addicted to
the life i'm addicted to yes fast money
yeah
yes
which is
yeah because i used to work
and wait for a check every [ __ ] two
weeks
uh but yeah of course that's all it's
about because when you get it you spend
it and you get it some more and you get
in
sometimes it's exciting here and it's
you know scary hair and it's you know
anger here and
happiness here but we all
just steady doing something
it's crazy
you you were just this is like the
longest i've sat still
you know i'm sick you know like where
i'm paying attention
because
my mind is always on
where am i going next yeah
i live i live i pay
thousand dollars me and a thousand
dollars a week where i said right
you know that shit's hard so we just
gotta hustle harder
especially
you know when you're paying a thousand
[ __ ] dollars a week
[ __ ] you would describe yourself i set
up dates all day you describe yourself
as a hustler
uh uh yeah
and and everyone's hustler because
hustle means you're hustling you're
you're you're you're figuring out ways
of trying to get yeah you're gonna get
it that's what means you're gonna get it
regardless of what you're going to get
it this is how you're going to do it in
your own mind so this is when i wake up
i got to hustle yeah but is it hard to
live in a life where
the tricks the pimps even the cops
everyone is a hustler all the other
girls on the street absolutely it's just
everyone even even
um
it's a
you know
you know every what is that what am i
thinking it's um
you know hate and and and a battle every
day
you know what i'm saying there's a lot
of corruption like everybody's
everyone's a snake
most definitely we all have it in us
what was the best time in your life
when i had my son well after i had him
because he was an ugly child when he was
first born so i well no i'm just kidding
but yeah when i had him he was like the
best that was the best [ __ ] memory of
my life and
um continues to be the greatest thing
that ever happened to me that's great
that cat is a cold cat
he's a good
smart
he's a good cat and what was the
worst time of your life worst thing
you've ever been through
um when i was 16
i had a boyfriend
they used to be this out beats the rape
when i got when i was 12. this cat used
to eat the [ __ ] out of me
um drinking when he would drink when he
would drink and um
man that that that moment in my life was
yeah i remember my heart like beating
like fiercely at end times you know what
i'm saying like that moment in my life
was
a cold moment i learned a lot from that
cat
that's the reason why i'm a fighter it's
because of that [ __ ]
you've been loved before
um
i
i think i have i mean you know what
with love was what i expected love to be
but it didn't last long it never lasts
long
i i'm in love with my son
[ __ ] yeah like as
as him be my son that's my
ace
i love you son
and your tricks are uh
respectable guys or
tell me about your customers for the
most part i mean you get one
depending on the type of chick you are
you know what i'm saying is what
what how you get treated you know
do you turn down some guys
i um okay so i um
i don't really i don't
we just don't go there i i listen to
people's story you know what i'm saying
sometimes you could look
but i still um i feel like i have a cold
energy i can feel
whether it's a good or bad situation i
should be able to check your intuition
guides you yeah it should have since i
was 12 i knew you know so
i have good intuition i think and uh
because it's been good but some people
are mentally
[ __ ] and don't you know
and so you know you got to just be
strong and sometimes you you know like
when i used to work on the street
um
you got to be
aware of who you're getting in the car
with because
you still never know even at the end of
it
you still don't know you know the thing
that's just crazy
kind of work because you're in you have
to adapt to this guy's personality and
then that guy's personality
yeah and one they could be so
drastically different right most
definitely and sometimes you'll see
something in somebody that you didn't
expect you know but um most definitely
you got to play your part that's the
hardest part that [ __ ] is
that's maybe the second hardest part of
this job most definitely because he's
adapting to all these different
personalities right and all these
different
bodies and stuff
you get you get asked to do crazy stuff
without a condom absolutely what with
yes these people
i mean it's
people are different yeah there's a lot
of different people out there i don't um
knock it
hell i'll embrace it for the right
amount of money but
there's some weird things that go on
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
that
my lesson is i know
what to look out for
my other lesson is um
if you don't expect anything
you won't be disappointed
i learned that
all right so i'm always disappointed
thank you so much for sharing your story
thanks very nice getting to know you
thank you
you